let's say that i've got some angle theta
some
angle data right over here and i'm
drawing it on our unit circle with a
typical convention that we started with
the ray that's along the positive x-axis
and the terminal side of this angle is
the terminal side of the angle where it
intersects the unit circle determines
essentially the sine and cosine of that
theta so the cosine of theta is the x is
the let me just in a color i haven't
used before the cosine of theta is the x
coordinate of where this terminal array
intersects the unit circle or another
way of thinking about it is
the cosine of theta is the length of
what i'm drawing in purple right over
here it's this length that length right
over there is cosine
of theta
and the sine of theta is the y
coordinate or another way of thinking
about it the sine of
the sine of theta
is the length of this line right over
here
the how high you are above the x-axis
that is essentially the y-coordinate and
so the length of that is sine theta
and this makes sense this is actually
this actually shows why the unit circle
definition is an extension of the
sohcahtoa definition
remember sohcahtoa let me write it down
sohcahtoa
so
tells sine is opposite over hypotenuse
so if i want to do the sine of theta
what's it going to be so if i think
about the sine of theta
sine of theta by the sohcahtoa
definition it's going to be equal to the
length of the opposite side well we're
saying that that's sine of theta
it's sine of
theta over the hypotenuse well the
hypotenuse here this is a unit circle so
it's going to be
1. so this shows that this this is
consistent or another way of thinking
about it
it is
another way of thinking about sine of
theta is equal to the opposite side
over the hypotenuse
in this case it's going to be equal to
the opposite side and what's the
hypotenuse this is a unit circle so it's
going to be 1. so in this case sine of
theta is equal to the length of the
opposite side the length of the opposite
side is equal to sine theta and same
exact logic the cosine of theta
the cosine
of theta is equal to adjacent over
hypotenuse
is equal to
adjacent over hypotenuse
and so that's since the hypotenuse is
equal to one that's just the length of
the adjacent side so cosine of theta is
the length of the adjacent side so this
is all a little bit of review just
showing how the unit circle definition
is an extension of the sohcahtoa
definition but now let's do something
interesting this is the angle theta
let's think about the angle theta plus
pi over 2.
so the angle theta plus pi over 2. so if
i were to essentially add pi over 2 to
this i'm going to get a ray that is
perpendicular to the first ray pi over 2
if we think in degrees pi over 2 radians
so when i say theta plus pi over 2 i'm
talking in radians pi over 2 radians is
equivalent to 90 degrees so we're
essentially adding 90 degrees to it
so this angle right over here
that angle right over here is theta
plus
pi over 2.
now what i want to explore in this video
and i guess this is the interesting part
of the video is can we relate
sine of
theta plus
pi
over 2
to somehow sine of theta or cosine of
theta and i encourage you to pause this
video and try to think this through on
your own before i work work it out
well let's think about what sine of
theta plus pi over 2 is we know from the
unit circle definition the sine of this
angle which is theta plus pi over 2 is
the y coordinate it's that it's this
value right over here or another way of
thinking about it it's the length it's
the length of this
line in magenta this right over here is
the sine
of theta
plus pi over 2.
so that right over there
now how does that relate to what we have
over here
well when you look at it looks like we
just took this triangle and we just kind
of we rotated it we rotated it
counterclockwise by 90 degrees which is
essentially what we did do because we
took this terminal side and we added 90
degrees to it or pi over 2 radians and
if you want to get a little bit more
rigorous about it if this whole if this
whole white angle here is theta plus pi
over 2 and the part that's in the first
quadrant is pi over 2 then this part
right over here that must be equal to
theta
and if we think about it if we try to
relate the side the side that i put in
magenta relative to this angle theta
using the sohcahtoa definition
here relative to this angle theta in
yellow this is the adjacent side
so let's think about it a little bit so
if we were so what deals with the
adjacent and the hypotenuse and in this
case of course our hypotenuse has length
one this is a unit circle
well cosine deals with adjacent and
hypotenuse so we could say that the
cosine of this theta
so the cosine
of that theta is equal to the adjacent
side the length of the adjacent side
which we already know is sine
of theta
plus pi over 2. let me write it this way
sine
of theta plus pi
over 2 over the hypotenuse
over the hypotenuse which is just one so
that doesn't change its value
so that was pretty neat just like that
we were able to come up with a pretty
neat relationship between cosine and
sine
the cosine of theta is equal to sine of
theta plus pi over 2 or you could say
sine of theta plus pi over 2 is equal to
cosine of theta now what i encourage you
to do is after this video see if you can
come up with other other results think
about what happens to how what what sine
of theta really relates to or or what
cosine of theta plus pi over 2 might
relate to so i encourage you to explore
that on your own